E
POCKET.
DAN: I'M NOT TRYING TO CUT YOU
OFF BUT I'M SO SORRY --
>> NO, APPRECIATE IT.
THANK YOU.
DAN: 45 DAYS INTO THE MIDTERMS.
EVER SINCE THE POLITICAL
EARTHQUAKE IN 2016, POLLSTERS
KEEP SCREWING UP.
POLITICAL ATTACKS ARE MAKING IT
HARDER THAN EVER.
THE ONLY POLLSTER WHO CORRECTLY
PREDICTED TRUMP'S 2016 VICTORY
SENIOR STRATEGIST, ROBERT, YOU
HAVE A FASCINATING PERSPECTIVE,
WHY POLLSTERS GETTING NUMBERS
WRONG AND UNDERREPORTING?
IS A PATENT.
>> IT CERTAINLY IS IN PART OF IT
IS THESE QUESTIONNAIRES AND THEY
LOSE AVERAGE PEOPLE.
2016 YOU HAD TRUMP VOTERS
HESITANT BECAUSE JUST TO SAY WHO
THEY WERE FOR, THEY DON'T WANT
TO BE JUDGED 2020 LEARY TO
PARTICIPATE IN A THINK THIS TIME
COULD BE WORSE.
DAN: I GOT ABOUT ONE MINUTE, YOU
HAVE A BRILLIANT STRATEGY YOU
ASK NEIGHBORS ABOUT HOW THEIR
NEIGHBORS WOULD VOTE, HOW DO YOU
ELIMINATE BIAS?
>> WE JUST ASK PEOPLE, HOW DO
YOU THINK YOUR NEIGHBORS VOTE?
IT ALLOWS PEOPLE TO EXPLAIN I'M
FOR HILLARY FOR MY NEIGHBORS ARE
FOR A TRUMP AND LET THEM SAY
THEY ARE FOR TRUMP WITHOUT BEING
JUDGED THIS YEAR OUR FEAR ALL
THE BIDEN HAS SAID IN THE PARENT
ATTACKS IN PEOPLE COMING AFTER
THEM THEY ARE HESITANT TO
PARTICIPATE.
EVERYBODY WILL UNDERESTIMATE AND
IT WILL EXCEED E